[Orientalische Musik]
[Verschiedene Gespräche]
Hinweis: Zum Zeitpunkt des Videodrehs existierte Covid-19 nicht.
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt oder heute zu Murats Welt.
Ich bin mit meinem Papa gerade in Denizli.
Wir besuchen gerade Unternehmen und lassen auch einiges produzieren.
Wir haben uns einmal gedacht,
wir machen mit dem Papa zusammen eine coole Denizli-Tour.
Papa, willst du auch etwas sagen?
PAPA: Alles schön.
MURAT: Ja, alles schön. Super!
Ich möchte euch nicht die Touri-Sachen zeigen.
Die coolen Sachen in Denizli möchte ich euch zeigen
- da, wo die Einheimischen hingehen.
Ein richtig cooles Video.
Denizli ist die zweitgrößte Stadt der Ägäis,
mit fast 1 Mio. Einwohner.
Denizli ist eigentlich für ihre Textilbranche bekannt.
Wir sind nicht deswegen hier, sondern wegen der Emaille-Branche.
Papa habe ich mitgenommen, sodass ich ihm einfach ein paar Sachen zeige.
Eigentlich zeigt er mir alles.
Ich möchte euch Land, Menschen und Kultur zeigen.
Deswegen gehen wir jetzt erst einmal essen, weil Essen uns verbindet.
Was Denizli beim Essen so ausmacht, das seht ihr jetzt.
[Musik]
So, ich bin hier mittendrin im Geschehen,
denn ich habe mich einfach reingeschlichen.
Denizli ist bekannt für Fırınlı Kebabı. Das ist ein Fleischgericht.
Das ist aus Lamm. [Fragt auf Türkisch nach]
Bu kuzu, degil mi? [Mitarbeiter stimmt zu.]
Genau. Kuzu ist Lamm. Das macht er im Ofen drin.
Es wird überall in Denizli gegessen,
wobei Denizli eigentlich keine Fleischhauptstadt ist.
Das ist mehr eine Hauptstadt für Vegetarisches.
Ich schau dem Usta, so nennt sich ein Koch bei uns, gerade zu.
Er macht hier das Fleisch. Richtig genial.
Das ist Lamm, wird dann auf so einem Brot im Holzofen gemacht.
Sieht richtig lecker aus.
Ellerine sağlik ustam.
„Ellerine sağlik“ heißt
„Mögen deine Hände niemals irgendetwas Schlechtes bekommen oder sehen“.
Boah, das schmeckt wie Hühnchen, nur Lamm. Mmh!
Salz drauf. Du brauchst gar nicht viel mehr tun.
Er tut wirklich nur das in den Ofen.
Josh, du kannst da einmal rein filmen.
Er macht das da drin. Er macht das Fett darüber auf ein Lavaş-Brot.
Und ein bisschen Salz, frische Zwiebel.
und dann wird das alles am Tisch auf einem Teller serviert
und alle essen zusammen.
Mein Schwiegerpapa ist auch da, ein paar Freunde ebenso.
Wir waschen uns jetzt alle die Hände,
denn es wird mit den Händen gegessen.
Das ist etwas ganz, ganz Besonderes.
Glaubt mir, wenn ihr mit den Händen esst, schmeckt es ganz anders.
So, jetzt sitzen wir am Platz. Das ist der Onur.
Er stellt uns die ganzen Emaille-Produkte vor.
Er macht den Verkauf.
Und mein Schwiegervater.
Die sind alle da und wir warten jetzt auf das Essen.
Das Essen ist richtig genial!
Das Besondere am Essen ist wirklich so:
Das ist ein freundschaftliches Essen.
Das heißt, man isst es wirklich mit der Hand.
Hier gehen alle mit der Hand rein.
Wir haben uns alle die Hände gewaschen.
Ich weiß, das sieht jetzt barbarisch aus.
Also Onur sagt mir, ein bisschen Pfeffer, Chili.
Dann nimmt man das so und macht das Fleisch mit der Hand drauf.
Zack, zack, zack.
So. Dann nimmt man hier die Zwiebel
und dann nimmt man noch eine Peperoni rein. So.
Jetzt essen wir es mal.
Mmh!
Es ist fettig. Es ist wirklich fettig, aber schmeckt unglaublich.
Dazu gibt es noch Ayran.
Aber ich sage euch ehrlich: eine Mordssauerei,
aber Denizli Kebap müsst ihr unbedingt essen.
Josh, jetzt bin ich mal dran mit Filmen.
Das Ding ist zerstört worden.
Das ist der absolute Wahnsinn!
Ich weiß nicht, was hier passiert ist.
Papa haut sich noch etwas rein. [Josh lacht]
JOSH: Der Mehmet macht es leer.
MURAT: Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir nachher weiterfilmen können,
weil wir einfach voll sind, gell?
Wir waren jetzt zu fünft und haben 300 türkische Lira ausgegeben.
Das sind ungefähr 10 € pro Person,
aber es waren auch 2 Portionen,
weil wir immer nachbestellt haben.
Auf jeden Fall geht es jetzt weiter in die Stadt. [Josh verneint]
Doch, doch.
JOSH: Wir können nicht drehen.
MURAT: Können wir nicht mehr drehen? Wahnsinn!
JOSH: Mein Bauch ist voll.
Und deiner auch.
MURAT: Absolut.
[Muezzin ruft zum Gebet]
Denizli hat natürlich auch eine Moschee.
Hier gibt es keine Kirchturmglocken.
Und zwar ruft jetzt der Muezzin zum Gebet
und alle Leute aus den Läden stürmen jetzt in die Moschee zum Beten.
Hier haben wir es ungefähr 14 Uhr;
das wird das Nachmittagsgebet sein.
Die Menschen gehen kurz beten, lassen ihre Läden wirklich offen.
Hier kommt keiner hin und klaut etwas.
Sie lassen die Läden offen, beten kurz
– das dauert ungefähr 15-20 Minuten -,
gehen in ihre Läden rein und machen einfach weiter.
Also eine ganz geniale Geschichte.
Ich war schon mal am Freitag hier.
Freitags verteilen sie auch Essen und Getränke an ärmere Menschen.
Das ist auch eine ganz tolle Geschichte hier.
Leider ist heute nicht Freitag,
sonst könntet ihr es selbst miterleben.
Es ist wie eine Gemeinschaft hier
und das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn.
[Muezzin ruft zum Gebet]
Das hat auch einen traurigen Hintergrund. Das sagt er gerade.
Und zwar ist von einem Einwohner aus der Stadt der Vater gestorben.
Er hat die Leute zum Gebet gerufen und gesagt (sinngemäß):
Hey Leute, hört zu!
Vom Hasan und Mehmet Araç ist der Papa gestorben.
Kommt deswegen zum Gebet und bitte macht… wie soll ich sagen?
Immer, wenn jemand stirbt, macht man ein Gebet,
das nennt sich El Fatiha.
Wenn ihr jetzt gerade zuschaut, dann macht das Gebet.
Wie gesagt, dieser Muezzin ruft gerade die Leute auf:
Kommt zum Gebet, lasst uns ein nettes Geleit machen
und sagen das El Fatiha auf.
Das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn.
Das ist eine Hammer Gemeinschaft hier.
Wie gesagt, das war nicht nur zum Gebet, sondern auch ein Ruf:
Hey Leute, da ist jemand gestorben.
Kommt alle her! Verabschieden wir uns!
Was ihr in der Türkei auch überall findet,
ist dieses getrocknete Gemüse.
Da sind Paprika, Okraschoten, Aubergine
- ich denke mal, das ist Aubergine.
Die werden hier getrocknet, auf einen Faden gehängt
und später bei der Zubereitung werden sie
einfach nur noch in heißem Öl frittiert
und es schmeckt mit Joghurt zusammen richtig lecker.
Ich zeige euch mal ein bisschen die Preise,
dass ihr ein Preisgefühlt habt.
Hier habt ihr z.B. so eine Kette.
Ich nehme an, dass es ganz viele Okraschoten sind.
Diese ganze Kette Okraschoten, einzeln auf den Faden gezogen,
kostet ungefähr 1,20 €.
Das da ungefähr 2 €, aber ihr müsst eines überlegen:
Das sind ganz, ganz viele Paprikas.
Wie gesagt, das wird nachher einfach in Öl erhitzt,
dann wird Joghurt darüber gegossen –
schmeckt richtig genial.
Das nennt sich – kein Spaß – „atom“ nachher.
Jetzt kaufen die Leute für das Fest morgen ein,
für den türkischen Nationalfeiertag.
Es ist überall die Hölle los.
[Musik]
Jetzt bin ich gerade beim Juwelier.
Ihr wisst ja selbst,
ihr findet überall in der Türkei Schmuckhändler – überall!
Also richtig massiv.
Nicht so wie in Deutschland,
sondern viele mehr.
Das hat aber einen wirtschaftlichen und historischen Faktor.
Der historische Faktor ist ganz einfach:
Gold wird den Leuten, wenn sie heiraten, als Mitgift mitgegeben.
Dann hat es noch einen anderen Faktor
– der wirtschaftliche Faktor ist folgender:
Die türkische Lira unterliegt ganz großen Schwankungen.
Wenn die Leute wollen, dass ihr Geld sicher ist,
dann legen sie es in Gold an.
D.h., wenn jemand Geld verdient hat und nicht möchte,
dass sein Geld an Wert verliert, legt er es in Gold an.
Das sind solche Gründe,
warum es überall in der Türkei diese vielen,
diese unglaubliche Anzahl an Juwelieren gibt.
Aber jetzt müssen wir Gas geben,
weil es hier in Denizli so unglaublich viel zu erleben gibt.
Wir laufen weiter.
Abi, Allah razı olsun. (Vielen Dank!)
Almanya‘ya birşey
söylemek ister misin? (Möchtest du Deutschland etwas sagen?)
VERKÄUFER: Sağ olun, teşekkür ederim. (Vielen Dank!)
MURAT: Okay. Also macht's gut. Bis gleich.
In Denizli ist Hacı Şerif ganz, ganz bekannt.
Es gibt es seit 1938. Habe ich das richtig gelesen? Genau.
Seit 1938 gibt es diesen Laden hier und…
Das ist voll lieb. Ach Gott, die bücken sich alle.
Hier ist es ganz bekannt – Baklava.
Hier gibt es aber nicht nur Baklava; hier gibt es auch…
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das nennt.
Das, was dieser junge Herr hier macht.
Das nennt sich Dondurma Irmik Helvası. So hat er ausgesprochen.
Mein Türkisch ist so miserabel.
Normalerweise würde es mich gerade dafür einsperren,
ohne Witz. [Josh schmunzelt]
Auf jeden Fall ist es dafür richtig bekannt.
Bir tane alabilir miyim? (Darf ich eins haben?)
So, er lässt mich das jetzt probieren.
Okay, jetzt macht der Eis rein.
Er macht das für uns extra langsam.
Normalerweise siehst du gar nicht, wie er das macht.
Jetzt kommt dieses warme… Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was Irmik Helvası ist.
Ich glaube, das ist warmer Gries oder so etwas.
Guck mal, jetzt kriege ich ein Wasser dazu.
Das gibt es automatisch, weil das richtig süß ist.
Und ich sage euch mal eins:
Wenn das jemand in Deutschland anbieten würde,
dann würden alle McDonald’s, alle Eisläden und Eisdielen zumachen,
weil das hammermäßig schmeckt.
Also was im Hacı Şerif nicht fehlen darf,
sind diese Baklava-Spezialitäten.
Baklava ist natürlich wirklich der Hammer!
Also hier ist alles voll mit Zucker.
Es ist alles nicht gesund, aber ich sage euch eins:
Wenn du im Hacı Şerif warst
und du hast einmal die Sachen probiert,
dann willst du da nicht mehr raus.
Es ist wirklich der absolute Hammer.
Hier schmeckt ein Ding besser als das andere.
Ich kenne hier viele Sachen, die ich euch nicht erklären kann,
weil sie einfach nur genial sind.
Dann gehen wir hier weiter, Josh. Komm mal mit!
Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal!
Komm mal mit, Josh! Komm mal mit!
Tadına bakabilir miyim? (Darf ich einmal probieren?) [Verkäuferin bejaht]
Guck mal, sie lässt mich sogar probieren,
weil sie denkt, ich wäre ein Fernsehstar.
Dabei bin ich ein kleiner dicker YouTuber.
Allah razı olsun. Sağ olun. (Vielen Dank!)
Verdammte Axt!
Josh, jetzt ohne Witz. Weißt du, wie genial das schmeckt?
JOSH: Schmeckt’s gut?
MURAT: Hammer!
Was auch cool ist:
Guck mal, die haben hier auch Lokum, so gummibärchenmäßig.
Ein bisschen anders, aber hier kosten z.B. 250 g 0,80 €.
Wahnsinn, oder?
JOSH: Voll günstig. [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Weißt du, was in Haribo drin ist?
Bei den Haribos sind, glaube ich,
nur 125 g drin und kosten 1,29 €.
Hier zahlst du für 225 g gerade einmal 0,80 €.
So, die begrüßen ihn alle. Wisst ihr, wer das ist?
Das ist der Besitzer. Das ist der Necip Abi.
Den habe ich gerade kennengelernt.
Er hat uns diese Bonbons geschenkt, einfach so.
Er ist einfach an uns vorbeigelaufen, schenkt uns diese Bonbons.
Und zwar ist das der Hahn. Es ist das Wahrzeichen von Denizli.
Den berühmtesten Laden in seiner Hood hat dieser Mensch,
schon in der 3. Generation. Der Laden gehört ihm.
Also wenn ihr mal nach Denizli kommt,
dann kommt zu Necip Abi zum Hacı Şerif.
Doğru mu? (Korrekt?) [Necip Abi stimmt zu]
Kaç yaşındasın abiciğim? (Wie alt bist du, Bruder?)
NECIP ABI: 67.
MURAT: Also er ist 67 Jahre alt und er lebt noch.
D.h., Zucker kann gar nicht so schlecht sein.
Die feiern mich gerade alle hier und kennen mich gar nicht,
aber Hauptsache, wir haben eine Kamera dabei.
Aber eine coole Geschichte.
Es gibt eine Geschichte zu dieser Statue hier.
Es ist ein Hahn, der einen Bademantel hat.
Ich habe gerade erzählt,
dass der Hahn das Wahrzeichen von Denizli ist, also wie hier.
Das andere Wahrzeichen von Denizli oder wofür es berühmt ist,
sind Handtücher.
Über 10 % der gesamten Textilindustrie entstehen hier.
Deswegen gibt es hier diese Bademäntel.
Diese Dame hier hat gerade zu mir gesagt:
Murat, tu mir einen Gefallen: Sag, dass es…
99 Textil, değil mi? (der Name von ihrem Textilgeschäft)
VERKÄUFERIN: 90.
MURAT: Und zwar heißt ihre Firma "90 Textil".
Da werden die schönsten Handtücher und Bademäntel hergestellt.
Das soll ich euch unbedingt nach Deutschland sagen. Süß, oder?
[Musik]
Ihr seht, es ist der Wahnsinn, was hier los ist.
Die Leute sprechen einen hier an.
Wenn man mit der Kamera irgendwo hineinläuft,
dann sagen sie: Hey, komm, filme mich!
Ich möchte meine Eltern und Verwandten grüßen.
Ich werde es nicht schaffen,
in den 24 Stunden euch ganz Denizli zu zeigen.
Kommt hier einfach her.
Was wir jetzt mache… Ich verspreche euch eins:
Essen ist jetzt fertig.
Jetzt gehe ich erst einmal ein bisschen gucken,
wo es noch richtig coole Sehenswürdigkeiten gibt – ohne Essen!
Wird es doch wohl geben, Josh, oder?
Ja! Dann probieren wir es aus.
[Musik]
Josh, kannst du mal kurz da hoch filmen
und zeigen, was ich jetzt mache?
Und zwar werde ich jetzt in diese Gondel steigen
und werde auf den Berg fahren.
[Musik]
Die Preise interessieren euch natürlich auch immer mal wieder.
Diese Gondeln kosten 8 türkische Lira, ca. 1,20 €.
Genau. 1,20 € kostet diese Hammerfahrt mit der Gondel.
Das tun wir uns einfach an. Ich freue mich richtig darauf.
Jetzt seht ihr Denizli von oben.
[Musik]
Wir sind jetzt mit der Gondel auf 1.700 m Höhe hochgefahren.
Dann sind wir aus der Gondel ausgestiegen.
Leider haben wir vergessen, es zu filmen.
Dann sind wir in den Bus hinein
und damit sind wir noch einmal 200 m in die Höhe.
Jetzt sind wir im Yayla.
Hier frühstücken die einheimischen Denizli am Wochenende
oder kommen zum Grillen hier hoch auf den Berg.
Für 1,20 € echt der absolute Wahnsinn.
Jetzt haben wir hier den ersten Bewohner getroffen.
Und zwar ist es Joshi, der Esel.
Auf jeden Fall ein ganz… Oh, guck mal!
Ich habe ein bisschen Angst vor Esel.
PAPA: Nein, keine Angst!
MURAT: Keine Angst, Papa? [Papa verneint] Okay.
Guck mal, der Esel ist uns einfach entgegengelaufen.
Der Wahnsinn, oder? Das ist ja mal cool.
Der Esel mag mich. Aber was für ein schöner Esel, oder?
Ich glaube, da sieht man auch, dass es hier kein Nutztier ist,
sondern dass er einfach nur rumsteht und gestreichelt werden möchte.
Oh, guck mal!
Ich glaube, von dir hätte ich…
Ah, Baba! Boah!
Auf jeden Fall – kein Problem!
Selbst wenn auf dem Berg ein Gorilla kommen sollte,
werde ich ihn dann umnieten.
Dann gehen wir weiter.
[Musik]
Von Denizli bin ich jetzt ungefähr 15 Min. mit dem Auto gereist.
Jetzt bin ich in Pamukkale.
Pamukkale ist eine kleine Stadt in der Nähe von Denizli,
ungefähr 3.000 Einwohner.
In Pamukkale ist eigentlich das Wahrzeichen der Türkei
- das meistbesuchte Wahrzeichen der Türkei
sind diese Kalkterrassen in Pamukkale.
Ich stehe gerade hier in einer Tür, wie ihr sehen könnt,
in Hierapolis. Hierapolis wurde 166 v. Chr. erbaut.
Man sagt, 16 Völker sind durch Hierapolis durchmarschiert.
D.h., christliche Religion, muslimische, Byzanz
und was weiß ich. Vielleicht waren auch die Wikinger hier.
So genau weiß das keiner.
Auf jeden Fall eine coole Ausgrabungsstätte natürlich.
Was nicht so lustig ist…
Es ist der größte antike Friedhof der Türkei mit über 1.200 Gräbern.
Jetzt laufen wir mal durch. Ich glaube, die Russen kommen.
[Musik]
Ich glaube, ich habe einen kleinen Archäologen in mir.
Jetzt seht ihr überall die ganzen Gräber. Das ist der Wahnsinn!
Wie mächtig und groß sie sind…
Wenn man sich überlegt: Wie haben sie das hier hochgebracht?
Wie haben sie diese Riesensteine in Form
und dann hier hochgebracht?
Das muss doch ein Riesenakt gewesen sein!
Wirklich, echt der Wahnsinn!
Ich stehe gerade mitten in einer Wasserleitung;
das nennt sich Aquädukt. Das haben die Römer perfektioniert.
Da merkt man: Jedes Mal, wenn die Römer irgendwo waren,
waren irgendwelche Wasserwege.
Aquädukt: Aqua heißt Wasser natürlich
und „dukt“ heißt „leiten / fördern“.
Ihr seht, es ist eine Wasserleitung.
Das ist einfach Arbeit mit verschiedenen Höhen.
Das haben die Römer gebaut.
Wir waren ja gerade in den Gräbern außerhalb der Stadt.
Jetzt gehen wir gleich in die Stadt hinein.
Da vorn ist das Stadttor. Davor war ein Hamam.
Hamam ist ein türkisches Bad.
Manche sagen auch Basilika dazu – wie auch immer.
Ihr könnt es nennen, wie ihr es wollt.
Der Grund war einfach folgender:
Die Leute konnten sich, bevor sie in die Stadt gegangen sind,
hier drin waschen und ins Bad hineingehen,
weil es wichtig war, dass keine Krankheiten in die Stadt reinkommen.
Das war ihnen damals einfach wichtig.
Deswegen haben sich die Menschen erst geduscht und gewaschen
und dann sind sie erst in die Stadt hinein.
Hier bin ich, wie gesagt, am Stadttor.
Es ist ganz genau genommen der Nordeingang zur Stadt Hiera.
Da laufen wir jetzt einmal durch. Sieht einfach genial aus.
100 n. Chr. gerade hier am Tor,
wenn du durch den Nordeingang reinkommst,
war auf der linken Seite die Latrine.
Latrine ist auch ein altes Wort. Manche von euch kennen es.
Latrine bedeutet übersetzt Toilette.
400 n. Chr. gab es wieder ein verheerendes Erdbeben.
Da hatte sich das Römische Reich in Byzanz
und das Römisches Reich geteilt.
Wie nennt sich die… ?
Wie heißt das Volk nach den Byzantinern?
Hießen die Byzantiner? Keine Ahnung. Tut mir leid.
Hieß es Byzantiner?
Aber es hieß doch mal Ferrero Byzantiner Königsnüsse.
Byzanz war geboren. Die Byzantiner haben dann
- ich hoffe, die heißen auch wirklich so –
die Steine nach dem verheerenden Erdbeben eingesammelt
und ein zweites Tor errichtet.
Das ist dieses Tor hier.
Dieses zweite Tor kommt nach dem Nordeingang.
Und das ist das Tor zu Byzanz. Wahnsinn, oder?
[Musik]
Jetzt sind wir natürlich im berühmten Pamukkale,
so wie ihr das natürlich kennt.
Pamukkale heißt Baumwollschloss
- übersetzt, wenn man das so sagen möchte.
Das ist ein Weltkulturerbe der UNESCO.
Das ist echt der Wahnsinn,
wie viele Leute jährlich hier herkommen,
um sich dieses Schauspiel hier anzuschauen.
Wir sind in der Ägäis.
Man kann Touren von Antalya
oder Alanya aus hierher buchen.
Pamukkale ist ein Wahrzeichen der Türkei.
Wenn man die Türkei, vor allem die Ägäis, besucht,
muss man hier vorbeigekommen sein.
[Musik]
Jetzt sind wir im Pamukkale der kleinen Leute.
Das würdet ihr niemals sehen, wenn ihr diese Touri-Trips macht.
Ich bin in Karahayıt.
Karahayıt ist auch ein ziemlich warmes Thermalwasser,
aber hier sind die Einheimischen.
Ein krasser Unterschied zwischen den Touris,
die dort oben auf dem Berg mit den weißen Terrassen sind
und hier die ganzen Normalos.
Richtig schön hier, richtig günstig.
Karahayıt ist so ein Geheimtipp von mir.
Da müsst ihr unbedingt vorbeikommen.
Jetzt schaut es euch einmal an!
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt gerade einfach an der Straße mit dem Josh angehalten.
Ihr müsst es euch so vorstellen:
Wir sind mit dem Auto gerade durchgefahren
und überall sind diese Wattebäuschchen.
Das war ein echt cooler Zufall, dass wir auf dem Weg
nach Buldan diese Baumwollpflanzen gefunden haben.
Jetzt haben wir wieder angehalten.
Klar, hier wird die Baumwolle natürlich gepflückt;
hier wird die Baumwolle auch verarbeitet.
Er ist der Besitzer dieser Anlage und er sagt,
die ganze Region bringt seine Baumwolle hierher.
Das ist sozusagen das Zentrum der Baumwolle in Denizli.
Er heißt mit dem Nachnamen Baumwolle.
Er heißt wirklich Ibrahim Baumwolle.
[Musik]
[Webgeräusche]
Wir sind gerade in Buldan.
Buldan ist in der Nähe von Denizli.
Buldan ist für den Leinenstoff sehr bekannt.
Der Herr hier, den ihr gerade gesehen habt,
webt diesen Leinenstoff per Hand.
Es sind diese Schals hier. Es ist dieser Stoff.
Es ist etwas ganz, ganz Feines.
Abi, sen bunları mı yapıyorsun? (Bruder, machst du diese hier?)
Bunları örmek icin kaç saat
sürüyor? (Wie lange brauchst du, um einen Schal zu weben?)
WEBER: Üc saat bir tane.
MURAT: Wow! Guck mal, er hat mir gerade gesagt,
er webt in 3 Stunden einen Schal.
Das kostet 130 türkische Lira,
das sind ungefähr 20-25 €.
JOSH: 20 €. [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: 20 €! Und dafür braucht er jetzt 3 Stunden,
um diesen Schal hier zu weben.
Er webt alles per Hand - überlegt mal.
Das kann man, glaube ich, als Kopftuch oder Schal benutzen.
Ich glaube, er macht sie hauptsächlich als Schals.
Guck mal hier!
Wie gesagt, ca. 25 € kostet es und er braucht 3 Stunden dafür.
Das ist ja mal cool.
Deswegen sind wir da.
Wie gesagt, dieser Ort Buldan kommt von Buldan Bezi,
also der Buldan-Stoff.
Es war eine coole Geschichte hier in Denizli.
Es ist auf jeden Fall eine Reise wert und richtig genial.
Wenn ihr mal in die Türkei und Ägäis kommt,
dann schaut mal in der Gegend um Denizli vorbei.
Geht an die Orte, die ich euch gerade gezeigt habe.
Es gibt noch viel, viel mehr,
aber für 24 Stunden war das schon richtig heftig.
[Musik]
Wir sind hier grade schon seit einer Stunde voll in der Rushhour.
In der Türkei ist es ein bisschen anders als in Deutschland.
Die Rushhour in Deutschland ist so zwischen 7 und 8 Uhr
und in der Türkei ist sie so zwischen 8 und 10 Uhr.
Die Türken fangen bisschen später an zu arbeiten als in Deutschland,
arbeiten aber wesentlich länger.
D.h., die Rushhour endet dann in der Türkei…
- wenn es in Deutschland zwischen 16 und 17 Uhr ist,
endet sie in der Türkei so zwischen 18 und 20 Uhr.
Es ist auch ein Riesenunterschied in der Türkei
im Gegensatz zu Deutschland.
[Musik]
So, hier im Hintergrund seht ihr den Deutschen Brunnen.
Er heißt wirklich so.
Und zwar war Kaiser Wilhelm II dreimal in der Türkei.
Bei seinem zweiten Besuch, 1998, sagte er zum Sultan Abdülhamid:
Ich schenke dir als Symbol unserer Freundschaft diesen Brunnen.
Das ist ein Zeichen der deutsch-türkischen Freundschaft.
Er steht seit 1901 immer noch hier.
Bei seinem dritten Besuch hatte er ihn mitgebracht.
Ihn hat wirklich ein deutscher Architekt gebaut,
einfach als Zeichen der deutsch-türkischen Freundschaft.
[Musik]
Jetzt sind wir im Hauptwahrzeichen der osmanischen Architektur.
Von 1609 bis 1616, also in 7 Jahren,
hat hier der Architekt Mehmet Ağa die Blaue Moschee gebaut -
die Sultan-Ahmed-Moschee.
Sie hat 6 Minarette.
Der Auftraggeber war damals Sultan Ahmed I.
Sultan Ahmed I sagte zu Mehmet Ağa:
Hör zu, mach mir die Minarette aus Gold.
Gold heißt auf Türkisch "Altın";
die Zahl 6 heißt "altı".
Er hat ihn falsch verstanden.
Er hat dann einfach 6 Minarette gebaut
statt 1 Minarett aus Gold.
Eine eigentlich ganz coole Geschichte.
Es ist, wie gesagt, ein Wahrzeichen der osmanischen Baukunst
und einfach, wie soll ich sagen, ein Hauptmagnet in Istanbul
- für die ganzen Touristen, für alle Menschen.
Es ist heutzutage immer noch eine Moschee. Wahnsinn!
[Musik]
So, wir sind jetzt gerade in Kayseri,
und zwar in Erciyes auf 2.096 m Höhe.
Hier liegt das ganze Jahr über Schnee.
Es ist ein großes ein Skigebiet der Türkei.
Das ist einfach der Wahnsinn.
Die ganze Landschaft ist so unberührt.
Wir zeigen euch mal die gigantische Landschaft.
[Musik]
Ja, wie gesagt, jetzt wird es kalt.
Jetzt haben wir schon -2°C.
Wir sind hier in einer der größten Skigebiete der Türkei.
Ich habe schon gesagt,
hier gibt es das ganze Jahr über Schnee,
und zwar richtigen Schnee,
keinen Fake Schnee mit Schneekanonen.
Es ist ein großes Skigebiet.
Das bauen sie gerade weiter aus.
Es ist eine geniale Geschichte, auch für die Leute hier.
Der Josh war, wie soll ich sagen, ein bisschen geflasht,
weil er ein Snowboarder ist
- der Josh hinter der Kamera.
Er ist richtig geflasht, wie es hier abgeht.
Das sind ein paar Japaner hochgefahren.
Jetzt nehmen wir die Gondeln
und werden einfach mal hochgehen und schauen,
wie es oben aussieht.
So, jetzt steigen wir ein.
Guck mal: Papa ist natürlich auch wieder perfekt mit seinen Sandalen.
Schön hoch!
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie kalt es oben ist.
[Musik]
Ja, Kayseri… Wahnsinn!
Wir haben leider viel zu wenig Zeit,
um das geniale Land überhaupt zu zeigen,
um Kayseri zu zeigen.
Ich bin im Schneegebiet.
Jetzt hat der Josh etwas entdeckt,
wovon ich gar keine Ahnung hatte.
Und zwar ist es so eine Downhill Bike-Strecke.
Da fährst du hier hoch und dann mit dem Mountainbike runter ins Tal.
Das ist wirklich ein unberührter Fleck Natur.
Das ist so genial
- gar nicht so viele Touris da.
Ich glaube, das ist ein absolut Geheimtipp.
Durch euch, weil ich euch das alles unbedingt zeigen will,
sehe ich Facetten und Dinge von der Türkei,
die ich selbst noch nicht kannte.
Wie gesagt, ein großes Schneegebiet mit Gondeln…
Der Hammer ist, mit der Gondel ganz nach oben zu fahren.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Kilometer es sind.
Das kostet gerade mal 1,20 €.
Es ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Also es ist vielleicht auch für euch ein Thema,
wer gerne Ski oder Downhill fährt,
wer einen richtig coolen Natur-Trip machen möchte,
jenseits und abseits von dem ganzen Massentourismus.
- es ist richtig genial hier.
Jetzt ist ein absoluter Geheimtipp für euch.
Tut mir einen Gefallen:
Kommt nicht alle, weil ich sonst nichts mehr davon habe.
Hammer, guckt euch mal die ganze Sache an:
Da vorn ist ein See, hier die ganzen Berge.
Die Luft ist so hammermäßig; die Luft ist so frisch,
dass es hier schon ein bisschen brennt.
Wahnsinn.
Ich will eigentlich nur auf den Berg, um mich dort oben zu übergeben.
[Musik]
So… Wahnsinn!
Was ich gerade sagen wollte:
Das ist eine türkische Drehtür.
Eine türkische Drehtür geht so… [Lacht]
Geil, das habt ihr auch noch nicht gesehen.
So, jetzt sitzen wir in einer Schneehütte.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das so nennt.
Ich war noch nie in einem Schneegebiet, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ich finde es einfach nur gigantisch.
Ich habe hier auch den Ismail kennengelernt.
Der betreibt jetzt diese Schneehütte hier…
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich hier „in den Bergen" sagen kann.
Wir sind hier auf 2.466 m Höhe. Es geht noch höher.
Es ist einfach genial, dass ich mal…
Ich lerne die Türkei selber kennen,
natürlich durch euch,
dass es hier ein Schneegebiet gibt,
in Kayseri übrigens das größte in der Türkei.
Was ich schade finde:
Viele von euch finden es vielleicht cool.
Hier sind nicht so viele Leute; finde ich aber trotzdem schade.
Es wäre schön, wenn noch mehr Leute da wären,
wir miteinander reden könnten,
Menschen von überall her kennenlernen könnten.
Es ist ein wunderschönes Skigebiet und es ist extrem günstig.
Ich habe mit dem Josh geredet:
Die Gondel kostet 1,20 €, um hochzufahren.
Das, was wir hier trinken, was wir hier essen…
Es ist wahnsinnig.
Ich habe hier etwas entdeckt.
Die Türken unter euch kennen es wahrscheinlich.
Das ist Salep.
Salep ist so ähnlich wie dickflüssige Milch,
ist aber aus einer Orchidee gemacht.
Es ist der Wahnsinn,
wie genial es schmeckt,
gerade auch hier in diesem Skigebiet.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Der Josh und ich haben schon gesagt:
Das müssen wir irgendwie nach Deutschland bringen.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob das erlaubt ist,
weil es aus der Orchidee gemacht wird.
Ich glaube, die steht in Deutschland unter Naturschutz.
Deswegen weiß ich es nicht ganz genau.
Deswegen machen wir jetzt nichts Falsches.
Wie gesagt, Ismail Abi:
Almanya'daki insanlara birşey söylemek ister misin?
Also ich hab mir gerade gefragt,
ob der den Leuten in Deutschland irgendetwas sagen möchte.
ISMAIL ABI: Burası Türkiye’nin en büyük kayak merkezi.
Tabii ki alman vatandaşlarımızı buraya da bekliyoruz.
En azından burada ki lezzeti,
Buradaki kayağı görmelerini illaki isteriz ve bekleriz.
Kayseri’yi tanımalarını isteriz.
MURAT: Okay. Also er sagt:
Alle Menschen, die jetzt gerade aus Deutschland zuschauen,
kommt hier gerne vorbei.
Es wäre schön, wenn ihr Kayseri
und die wunderbare Landschaft hier kennenlernt.
Und ja… so viel habe ich selber verstehen und übersetzen können.
Ich denke, das wird reichen.
Teşekür ederim İsmail abi. (Vielen Dank, Ismail abi).
Wir trinken weiter Salep. Das ist der Hammer.
Das ist übrigens Joshs Becher,
Unser zweiter schon, also zwei von ihm, zwei von mir.
Wirklich der Wahnsinn.
[Musik]
Also wir sind jetzt in Kappadokien.
Das ist in der Nähe von Kayseri.
Es ist eine gute Stunde von Kayseri entfernt.
Es ist so, wie soll ich sagen, ein Monument.
Es ist auch ein Weltkulturerbe.
Hier wohnt eine ganze Stadt in einem Berg drin.
Das heißt, die haben sich wirklich über tausende Jahre
ein ganzes Konstrukt durch den Berg durch gemacht.
Da geht es teilweise 10 km durch die Berge durch.
Da haben sie sich Wohnungen gebaut, alles in Stein gemeißelt.
Das sind auch solche Monumente…
Da fragt man sich, wer diese Steine oben draufgelegt hat.
Das sind riesige Hinkelsteine.
Kappadokien muss ich euch empfehlen!
Wenn ihr mal Kappadokien bei Google eingebt…
Da sind diese Bergstädte mit diesen Heißluftballons.
Also Heißluftballons kann man ja fahren.
Also eine gigantische Kulisse!
Ich war so geflasht.
Ich wollte eigentlich die Stadt aufnehmen,
aber ich habe es einfach verschlafen,
weil ich einfach so geflasht war
und die Kamera einfach ausgelassen habe.
Aber Kappadokien ist etwas Hammermäßiges.
Guck mal, Josh, das sieht doch hammermäßig aus, oder?
Wer hat diesen Stein oben draufgelegt?
Weiß es jemand?
Guck mal!
Da hinten seht ihr es ein bisschen.
Da haben sie wirklich Löcher in die Felsen gegraben.
Das sieht so hammermäßig aus.
Da hinten kann man es auch noch sehen.
Da waren wir vorher überall
und es ist echt der Wahnsinn gewesen.
[Musik]
So, das war jetzt der Abend in Kappadokien.
Unglaubliche Geschichte, was wir hier erlebt haben.
Ich hätte es niemals gedacht.
Allein Kayseri.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Eine Stadt, eine riesengroße Stadt, über 1 Mio. Einwohner.
Dann fährst du eine Stunde und bist im Skigebiet.
Und dann fährst du noch einmal eine Stunde und dann bist du in…
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich Kappadokien erklären soll.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man in Deutschland Kappadokien so kennt.
Ich glaube, das ist den Menschen noch gar nicht bewusst,
dass es dieses Fleckchen Erde auf der Welt gibt.
Es ist unglaublich!
Es ist eine unglaubliche Gegend. Wirklich!
Ich kann es euch wirklich nur empfehlen.
Jetzt hocken wir mit dem Papa zusammen am Lagerfeuer,
mit Mustafa abi - das ist der Inhaber der Gusseisenfirma,
wo wir unsere Gusseisentöpfe herstellen lassen.
Er hat uns wirklich ganz, ganz lieb herumgeführt.
Wir waren in genialen Läden.
Leute haben uns überall eingeladen.
Die wollten kein Geld von uns haben.
Es war echt der Wahnsinn
und eine unglaubliche Geschichte für mich.
Türkei mal wieder ganz neu entdeckt,
von einer ganz anderen Seite entdeckt.
Ich kann es euch wirklich nur empfehlen.
Papa, willst du noch etwas sagen?
Willst du noch eine Geschichte erzählen,
wo wir gerade am Lagerfeuer sind?
Ja?
Okay. Der Papa erzählt uns noch ein paar Geschichten am Lagerfeuer
und wir sehen uns wieder in Deutschland.
[Musik]